what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so over the years Marvel has
released different types of stories you
know like you have the ultimate universe
which is the answer to the question what
would it be like if superheroes came
into existence in like the modern day
and of course you've got classic Marvel
and you've got things like Marvel's you
know like ma AR ve LS which is like hey
here's like this idyllic perspective of
like the rise of superheroes and then we
have ruins and ruins
it's a Warren Ellis story and holy help
ruins is like the worst case situation
right like like you should any ask a
question you're like hey how bad could
things possibly get in the Marvel
Universe and then like you asked that
question and somebody says well here
read marvel ruins and you'll find out
like it is it is bad like it is it is so
messed up so this all comes from a
perspective of a guy named Philip
Sheldon what this does is it initially
kind of gives us like this opening
perspective right like it kind of starts
with the idea of the Avengers in the
sense that what you had is you had Tony
Stark who was gonna put his mind to task
and he was gonna like basically in the
whole like conflict in Vietnam and all
that kind of good stuff and like much
like the main Marvel Universe he was you
know he went overseas he was captured
and he basically created the Iron Man
suit and he came back to the United
States the difference here is that he
and the other Avengers basically helped
to try to allow California to secede
from everybody and they failed like it
was like they literally tried to help
like like an insurrection basically in
the United States and it all came
crashing down and the result was that
Tony Stark alongside all the other
Avengers basically died but it gets
crazy it gets crazier okay so from here
we switch over to filled up Sheldon go
into a bond I remember he's documenting
how quote unquote everything went wrong
about how everything went all screwed up
but we get these small little tidbits
here and there for example you pick up
with um like the atomic truck crash that
basically gave daredevil his enhanced
senses when it blinded him and in ruins
it kills him like he just dies like it's
like he dies in a pretty horrific way
basically just like radiation and
chemical burns end up killing him but
Philip Sheldon goes to this bar and he
basically encounters like Wolverine but
Wolverine like with regards to how his
how his whole situation works instead of
him having adamantium and then basically
having like adamantium claws that give
him like all kinds of crazy abilities he
has those but like it's basically
poisoning his bones so imagine what you
in the film Logan but imagine that it's
always been that way and not only that
like like he's got like these nasty
scars and like these protrusions and
everything's like that and it's kind of
crazy because the local barkeep kind of
uses him is like a sort of side to side
attraction basically like you know hey
man like like dude show this guy your
scars I'm sure how screwed up York and
I'll give you a drink and like like he
does like he shows you know Philip
Sheldon how screwed up he is and so like
the barkeep gives him a drink and like
that's it like that's that's all you get
from him but it's like small things here
and there you know like for example like
a black panther T'Challa actually joined
the Black Panther organization and he
alongside like Bobby Seale and Huey
Newton are just serving prison serving
time in a San Francisco prison park I
was shot in the head Scarlet Witch was
actually the one who betrayed the
Avengers like she turned state's witness
so the idea was that she was part of the
Avengers team originally but when the
federal government was trying to find a
way to basically crack down on the
Avengers and in the insurrection like
she basically sided with the federal
government she told him everything they
wanted to know and the result was that
during the whole point where the
Avengers were basically like helping to
launch the secession in California there
Quinn jet was shot down by the federal
government using a Patriot missile and
that's what killed them all so like
Scarlet Witch was the one that got them
all killed but from here like we switch
over to to Nevada
basically like to a nuclear testing site
and this is bonkers so what we end up
finding out here is the federal
government is basically built like a
giant encampment here and inside this
encampment is the Kree race and or at
least what's left of the Kree race like
those individuals who travel to earth
and it's really really screwed up
because the adults know why they're
there because like they were captured
you know by the American people but like
kids are born inside this camp and they
don't know why they're there and so
Phillip Sheldon basically makes his way
in after being allowed by the by the
various soldiers who of course are
wearing radiation suits and we end up
finding out that he's actually meeting
with with marvel of the of the Kree race
now in the main Marvel Universe the way
that's played out is Marvel was tasked
by the supreme intelligence to lead an
invasion airy force against the planet
Earth and then ultimately Marvel turned
against the Kree and became a superhero
on earth and that's what led to like
jaan raghav Marvel basically becoming
the other two of them coming you know
becoming mortal enemies but basically he
was a superhero on earth fighting
alongside the Avengers and fighting on
behalf of humanity against the creek in
this story it doesn't happen that way
instead what we end up finding out here
is that the mission parameters of the
Kree were still the same and this is if
they were tasked with traveling to earth
the difference was that along the way
they basically encountered the Silver
Surfer and the idea here was that the
Silver Surfer you know nor
after being turned into the Silver
Surfer by Galactus had basically gone
insane because of the fact that he was
so used to being a mortal being who
basically breathed oxygen once that
transformation happened he literally
lost his mind in an effort to try to
breathe again and like tore open his
insides and just died of shock and space
and so because of the fact that he was
still like imbued with all this cosmic
power the result was that when the Kree
warship showed up and then hovered there
for a minute or two the power cosmic
eliminated their cloaking system which
revealed their existence to the world
and in response the United States
started launching nuclear missiles into
space and the result was that like all
these tomahawk canoes Tomahawk missiles
just like bombarded the cruise ship
we're sitting at crashing down to earth
and those who survived was only like a
tenth of them survived those who
survived were taken captive and to be as
much like an example as an experiment
and they're literally just like thrown
you know in in Nevada and like this
nuclear testing ground so basically
they're all irradiated with cancer and
like they're they're all gonna be dead
within like 30 years the other half of
this is that Charles Xavier has become
President of the United States and like
he lives in seclusion like you never see
professor X which I imagine is a kind of
an illusion of sorts to FDR in the sense
that you never really saw FDR in a
wheelchair you'd see him like sitting
down but you wouldn't really see him
rolled out in gym you know in the
general public in a wheelchair but the
idea here is that Philip Sheldon travels
to the capital to Washington DC which is
essentially just like completely and
totally collapsed like the the city is
just a place of destitution and squalor
like it's it's absolutely heinous but
what he had done is he had secretly
written to Nick Fury of shield now the
crazy thing about this is that much like
the main Marvel Universe Nick Fury seen
and done it all and the main Marvel
Universe in in World War 2 Nick Fury led
the Howling Commandos and then they came
along the like they came into contact
with the Infinity serum and the result
was at the Infinity formula basically
granted them immortality so long as they
consumed it on a like I think it was a
yearly basis the issue and what we found
out in original sin was that the
Infinity formula eventually ran out so
all these young versions of Nick Fury
that we saw running around the Marvel
Universe we're actually a life model
decoys and the real Nick Fury was just
an old guy sitting on a satellite that
nobody knew about there was completely
cooked from all forms of detection and
so like that blue kinda blew the top off
the whole Nick Fury thing but in this
story like he's seen and done it all
like from his perspective he's like look
man like everything went wrong like we
don't even know where went wrong but
like the Avengers are dead the mutants
are basically like like experiments that
are done like like all kinds of things
are messed up one of the other things
that happens to you is it like
great is kind of like wanders up to the
two of them and is like like literally
like pens herself out basically and it's
like hey I'll do anything you want for
like 20 bucks and it's like god this is
screwed up like ma'am it's like this is
this is absolutely messed up not only
that like the indication here is that
she's underage so my gifts it's enough
it's like in a really dark spot but of
course Nick Fury like when when he
realizes what she's about he literally
just caps her and like that's the end of
Jean Grey and then from there he
basically turns it on himself and he's
like dude I've seen so much so many
screwed up things and I've seen how like
messed up this place is I don't want to
be a part of it anymore and like that's
the end of Nick Fury and those so not
only that like what we ended up finding
out here is that galactus exists in this
universe but Galactus is just like
floating out in Mars like he's dead
we don't know what killed him we don't
know what happened to him we just know
he's not there anymore like he's
basically just out of the picture and so
at this point we switch over to Phillip
Sheldon meeting with oh my god Marlo
Chandler holy cow Morelos handler and
and Wow Daimon Hellstrom those are names
I haven't heard in a long time
Marlo Chandler was this chick she was
like super athletic and like a personal
trainer or something like that and and
she was the girlfriend of Joe fix-it who
was the alternate personality of the
Incredible Hulk when he was when he was
taking up residency in Vegas and didn't
want anybody to know who he was when he
was just like the grey Hulk when it came
to Damon Damon hellström okay so the way
this worked out is in Marvel Comics
you've got like different versions of
Satan basically you've got like Mephisto
you've got actually Satan himself like a
being who operates as Satan more or less
but the idea is a Daimon Hellstrom would
be like like satan born in the mortal
world kind of like an heir to the throne
or something along those lines he goes
all the way back to like Ghost Rider and
like I want to see his Ghost Rider vol 2
issue number 3 in like 1973 or something
crazy like that he goes way back but
anyway like like we don't even really
get a glimpse of Daimon Hellstrom it's
just like this chick who's just like my
son's gonna be the Messiah one day and
so like things are totally screwed up
here because Marlon it's basically like
a smack addict a junkie but not only
that we actually get this crazy story
from Rick Jones so when the main Marvel
Universe the way the Incredible Hulk
story played out originally was that you
had the gamma bomb that was going to be
tested by like Bruce Banner and these
guys to see what sort of energy sources
could be used for a lot with like gamma
radiation and Rick Jones was just this
mindless stupid kid who was literally
playing on a banjo on in a car at like
the testing site because you know I
guess it kind of made sense with like
all the horns and the countdowns and hey
this is a cool place to practice music
and so like he's so easy sitting in that
in that little area and Bruce Bay
realizes he's there so banner goes
running out to the testing site and
pushes Rick Jones out of the way banners
caught in the gamma bomb explosion and
The Incredible Hulk is born in this
story the event plays out the exact same
way the difference here is that banner
becomes a Hulk kind of but not in the
same capacity what is up happening here
is it like once he's basically hit with
like all this energy from the gamma bomb
he literally just turns it like this
giant mass of tumors and it is it is
hideous like it is it is dark and
twisted I mean like his eye pops out of
his head and like tumors just start
exploding out of him and so like he's
giant and green but he's just like like
bones protruding just like this giant
hulking mass of just tumors and cancer
and like like the idea or at least the
way it's explained by Rick Jones is that
like they keep him alive and he's
actually like in a vault like he's in a
vault under a lake and they they keep
him alive they test on and they
experiment on him we never see him after
this like we never actually find out
what happened to him we just know he's
there at least Rick Jones says he's
there not only that of course Rick Jones
is basically just like drinking morphine
Biden just like this jar of morphine
which of course is designed to basically
you know keep cancer at bay but like
things are rough because like it's like
the Punisher you end up having like
Philip Sheldon who's making his way and
the Punisher was basically just gunned
down now again we're not really given an
explanation there about what happened to
him we assume he was killed by criminals
which makes the most sense like you've
got you know Frank Castle is like I'm
gonna wage a war on crime and it lasts
like that like it lasts almost no time
at all
and he's taken out lickety-split and
like that's the end of him but then you
pick up with like one of the most
screwed up parts of it so after this
whole experience
Philip Sheldon's on a plane and
basically he's sitting by a neo next to
a woman that he calls mr. crome who of
course is mystique but like as soon as
like when he sits down she immediately
starts going crazy right it's like it's
like the scene from Total Recall you
know two weeks two weeks you know like
like just start like you know just
starts going nuts and and like her face
starts distorting and everything come to
find out what had happened was that she
she developed the ability to shape-shift
but because of the fact that she had
taken on like the different forms of so
many people it basically gave her a
multiple personality disorder and her
head literally just like caved in and
just killed her on the spot because she
wasn't taking pills they were designed
to keep that from happening not only
that like once he and everybody else get
off the plane in an evacuation what you
end up having here is like this guy who
just kind of like walks up and then he's
pushed out of the way by by one of the
security guards only for us to find out
that what had happened is that this guy
had this sort of device around his body
it was designed to basically like keep
his magnetic powers at bay of course
this turned out to be magneto but when
he was pushed out of the way the
dampening field was damaged and the
result is that like his magnetic powers
are completely uncontrollable and it
rips out everything like like it goes
nuts like the iron in people's bodies
it's like ripped out of their bodies
entirely it kills him on the spot
fillings are torn out of fill to fill of
Sheldon's mouth like guns go flying
towards him and then eventually like the
entire plane just comes to like it
literally gets pulled in by the magnetic
abilities of magneto and it just like
explodes on him and kills everybody in
the immediate vicinity now of course
like like Philip Sheldon bailed out like
it's like really fast like he got out of
there while the getting was good but
then at that point you switch over to
Texas and this is when we find out how
dark Professor Xavier is as president
what he's been doing here is that unlike
the main Marvel Universe where he
basically takes mutants and then brings
them to the Xavier Institute and teaches
them how to use their powers instead
what he does is he sends him to like
this top-secret facility more or less
that's ran by Wilson Fisk the kingpin
and they're just like experiments and so
it's crazy because stuff likes like
Cyclops because of the fact that his
eyes are or you know emit optic beams
they didn't know how to control it and
so they basically just like blinded him
and soon as his eyeballs shut and it was
just like damn I mean like like
literally melted his eyeballs closed
I guess it's crazy how this whole things
happens like Kitty Pryde had tried to
escape because she can phase through
things and she got stuck in a wall and
lost three feet of intestine like
nightcrawlers just cannibalizing himself
I like Quicksilver lost his arms and
legs because the momentum and the
friction in the air is he moved weren't
like his his arms and legs couldn't
handle it and like the crazy thing is
that Xavier will come down there and
Xavier will just talk to the like he'll
just stare at him or he'll talk to him
or something like that but like the
implication here is that like things are
not the way they're supposed to be
they're like they weren't supposed to
turn out this way that somehow
everything got screwed up and so what
you end up doing is you end up finding
out that like for example Donnell Blake
is not Thor in this story instead he's a
guy who claims to have seen Thor and
he's literally holding like a regular
hammer he's basically a maniac who had
essentially just gotten high on some
shrooms and never recovered and so they
just kind of chalk it up to him just
being stalking like a hallucinogenic
state forever Emma Frost leads this
crazy like religious organization that
actually goes through and like adopts
the kids of its members and then
performs like these brain experiments
more or less to like awaken their
psychic powers but she's basically just
like a crazy chick and then you have
Johnny Blaze Johnny Blaze actually kind
of has the
like none of these stories are really
funny per se but like this one kind of
is so like Johnny Blaze Johnny Blaze is
like this daredevil right like like much
like the main Marvel Universe he's like
this stuntman daredevil kind of
character what happens is that in this
whole like traveling carnival act he's
called Saint John and he just performs
like these crazy stunts well in this one
it's like the last stunt he'll ever
performed what he does is he douses his
head and gasoline sets it on fire and
then like ghosts to perform a stunt only
to die in the process and just ride off
into the desert and like that's the end
of him but like that's kind of a tribute
to the whole like you know flaming head
of Ghost Rider like it's it's it's it's
so screwed up but it's kind of nuts
because then what you have is you have
filled up Sheldon who actually ends up
in New Orleans I think and starts to
like a dream of this time when
everything was different you know when
the world isn't the way that it is right
now like he dreams of like a better
tomorrow and it's this whole idea that
what he basically ends up dreaming is
the marvelous story by Marc Wade and
Alex Ross where it's like this Age of
Heroes and like everything was the way
it was supposed to be you know and like
Captain America is a champion of the
people and Tony Stark helped to form the
Avengers and mutants and all these
different beings are like saviors of the
world you know helping to protect from
like these various threats that exist
out there but like that doesn't exist
and so what we do you know for this last
little tidbit of the story we pick up
with Ben Grimm this is kind of the
coolest thing because we basically get
this explanation of what went on with
the Fantastic Four so in the main Marvel
Universe the Fantastic Four as we know
Reed Susan Johnny Storm and then of
course Ben Grimm had basically taken off
into space they were hit with cosmic
rays they fell back to earth and of
course they gained their powers instead
what ended up happening here is that in
this particular story or at least in
this particular universe that when Reed
Richards wanted to take off when he was
like hey we want to use this vessel and
fly into space Ben Grimm's response was
this thing's not ready like you do not
have maneuverability on this vessel like
you're literally just a rocket firing in
a forward direction what you need is the
ability to like maneuver and move around
so that if you start running into
problems you can evade them but Reed
Richards didn't want to do that instead
what he wanted to do was immediately get
into space and chart as best he can now
the indication here was that this was in
response to the Russians or at least the
idea was that it was basically the great
space race and they wanted to get people
into space before the Russians and so
instead of instead of having Ben Grimm
pilot the shuttle they basically got
like Victor Von Doom who there's really
no indication here that he's like Doctor
Doom dabbling in like magic and
mysticism instead he's just one of the
people who worked there but when they
fly the shuttle into space they're hit
with
mccrane the difference here is that
Johnny Storm he does set on fire and he
burns to a crisp like Susan storm is is
really just kind of like they're like
I'm she was basically invisible turned
her eyes to glass and like she was
completely and totally blind
no one knew she was there until like she
tripped over her brother or you know or
somebody tripped over her and then it
like Reed Richards was basically able to
stretch and then rigor mortis set in so
he's just like this elongated corpse
more or less and the craziest thing was
dr. doom they don't show you what
happens to Victor Von Doom but the the
idea here was that he had basically just
turned to mineral like he turned inside
out don't like his organs were on the
outside of his body and then they became
like a hardened mineral and like he just
somehow landed back on earth or
something along those lines but it's
crazy because Phillips Sheldon has
basically been dying this whole time and
you end up finding out the reason why
he's dying is because Peter Parker had
like exposed himself to the you know
this really screwed up virus in an
effort to like gain powers and the
result is that like his physical form is
all like screwed up and in terrible and
like disfigured but because of the fact
that Phillips Sheldon had met him when
he was younger and then shook the hand
of Peter the illness passed on to him
which is basically been killing Sheldon
the entire time I mean the result is
that Sheldon just dies in the story ends
that's it like it's the least grand
ending ever but it's like the small
things in there like like a more The
Enchantress who in the main Marvel
Universe is designed to be like a very
luscious and full-figured woman she's an
adult film star in the Marvel ruins line
of comics and like I think she kills her
manager or somebody like that there's a
lot of things you don't learn though
like I don't think you ever learn about
what happened to Loki um I don't think
you ever learn about like how Asgard
works or anything like that but it is it
is like this is like twisted this is
just depressing as hell but anyway guys
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section about this whole
story if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and about who would like
I mean I guess it's kind of a cool story
but this is one I highly suggest you
read because it's really immersive like
when you get into it's just like yeah
I'm like it's like it makes you want to
know like look give me more like I want
to know more about what happened like as
dark as it is I want to know more about
this universe it's pretty screwed up but
anyway guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]